audit logs and Google cloud provided in
the mutable record of how resources and
data are created modified and accessed
but knowing what's locked by default and
what you have control over can be
confusing let's walk through setting you
up and reading audit logs to understand
what's really going on on your project
this is the stack dr. actions the touch
Google Cloud resources or data within
those resources create an audit trail
but where do you go to see that trail
you can start on the activity tab of the
home page of your project this is a view
of all of the audited events in your
project and you get more information
about what happened for beach event
let's look at a specific example we'll
use cloud storage and look at both
out-of-the-box audit logs and those you
can enable yourself start by creating a
cloud storage bucket with a name and
default options feel free to delete this
after you're done now switch back to the
activity tab and refresh once the buck
is being created you'll see a new event
showing the resource that was created
the user who created it and the
timestamp of the event you can also go
to logging in the GCP console and see
the matching log entry it's an activity
log and the type is said to audit log
it's pretty straightforward
you created a resource and the log
entries written however if you try
adding a file to your new bucket you'll
see that no additional activity or log
entries are generated as a result this
is because operating on objects in
buckets is interacting with user data
not creating or modifying resources and
themselves to lock these actions only to
enable additional audit logging you can
find the audit logging configuration
under the I am and admin section of the
products menu this screen shows you the
kinds of audit logs you can enable for
GCP services you should know that system
event an admin activity audit logs are
always enabled and cannot be turned off
there are three kinds of data access to
audit logs you can enable admin read
logs or written when you access resource
configuration or metadata data read logs
are written when user data within a
resource is accessed and data write logs
are written when data within a resource
is created let's continue with our
example to clarify if you enable admin
to read audit logs and refresh the book
of you in a console you'll see that a
new event is written this is a record of
you access sending the resources and
metadata and configuration the actual
log entry will show
a call to the storage buckets get API if
you enable data read audit logs and
refresh the bucket you'll see an event
reading written for accessing resource
data logging your call to the storage
objects list API if you then retrieve a
file from your storage bucket you'll see
another event created showing you
accessing the resources data the log
entry shows a call to the storage
objects get API finally if you enable
data write audit logs and create a new
file in the bucket you'll see an event
for inserting data logging in call to
the storage objects create API that was
a lot let's review the kinds of audit
logs you can enable and what actions
they can actually record you can turn on
three kinds of audit logs admin read for
reading metadata and configurations data
read for reading user data and data
write for creating or writing user data
within resources because these are user
controlled they do incur logging charges
in the same way as other logs on your
project system event and admin activity
logs are always written cannot be
disabled and therefore don't incur
logging charges audit logging is
invaluable as you work to keep your
deployments in GCP secure and compliant
knowing how to use our logging to get a
clear record of what happened in the
project is essential to keeping your
Google Cloud projects secure and I hope
that this helps you to better understand
how to do that thank you for joining me
today and come back soon for more this
is the stack doctor stay healthy out
there
you
[Music]